[Music]
foreign
folks welcome to the 168th Darkhorse
podcast live stream with me Dr Brett
Weinstein this is Dr Heather Hein and we
are ready
I don't know about that but Google does
not think we're ready but we are ready
in light of all that has taken place in
our lives this week we are shockingly
ready let's put it that way this is true
this is true yes a lot of things
including I spent several days looking
like the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
really yeah you weren't here does it
sound like you look like that on the
phone so I mean this I I just got so
puffy and I was trying not to be Vain
about it I didn't say anything to anyone
I was meeting and I was like wow I look
ridiculous and I saw my amazing
osteopath yesterday he was like oh man
you got some blockages and just drained
away there was fluid caught up there in
the tissues so yeah remarkable
remarkable that sort of thing can happen
to a person yeah physiology is uh
surprisingly complex yeah the diagrams
in the uh the intro textbook they just
don't do it justice they really don't in
part because they're you know diagrams I
guess I guess that's kind of it static
2D doesn't quite I mean physiology is
intrinsically Dynamic Anatomy also but
less so but physiology is like the
dynamic
um Downstream stuff Associated that is
that is built on the foundation of
anatomy not only that but
um inherently the most complex stuff in
the universe is the biology and in order
to get it simple enough to get you to
understand anything new they have to
purge so much of the complexity that it
uh creates a false impression inherently
I've always thought this was a
fascinating defect in our cognitive
model of neurons because the number of
dendrites that connect them to other
neurons is spectacularly large often in
the thousands right and yet in order to
see the picture of the neuron so you can
understand how the signals come in you
know it's 8
right yeah it's like one input and eight
outputs like oh that could be thousands
yeah you could be off by orders of
magnitude which which then takes you
puts you off in terms of imagining what
kind of emergent properties are possible
and what level of complexity is possible
yeah it uh it does not properly
represent the system
all right let us uh start Logistics well
so we're gonna today we're going to talk
a little bit about
um
Thomas Seoul and you're going to come
back to the topic of AI a bit and we're
going to finish the hour by talking
about the hour two hours Whatever It Is
by talking a little bit about penises
penai I think you're not being an eye
all right
I said hemipines right or ball peens
hammers you know
as a woman which I am I don't identify
as one I just am one and you identify as
I would never have introduced ball peen
hammers into a discussion of penises
yeah done it it doesn't seem safe
doesn't seem kind
just saying if you were gonna get hit
with a kind of hammer actually a ball
peen hammer would be uh it's not good
but it's definitely just for the record
I did not introduce the idea of hitting
of hammers of hand tools at all right in
the nope for the record having
introduced do you any of these topics
into the discussion that you were
attempting to seed so yes I uh I succeed
control oh wow different seed okay
don't tell me they're spelled
differently so differently are they yes
oh all right I was um you know today
years old when I learned that they were
spelled differently yes and and yes okay
so all of that is Is Yet To Come uh but
first we follow these live streams
mostly uh but today we are going to be
following this live stream with a live q
a you can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com next week we
will not be having a q a and the week
after that we're actually going to be
off entirely so this is your last chance
to ask questions for the live q a for
three weeks I guess uh and um and do so
if you have questions for us again at
darkhorsesemissions.com
please consider checking out my weekly
writing at Natural Selections this week
I did not update my notes Here I wrote
about the sleep of seals which I will
just uh drop this little tantalizing
nugget is how I ended up wanting to talk
about penises today
all right the sleep of seals you know
the seals sleep with the fishes uh they
do
yes true all right now this has gotten
suddenly so phylogenetic that people are
changing
yes yes yes okay so we also have a store
uh it is a store dot dark yes please
show it and tell me what the URL is
because I always forget
store.darkhorsepodcast.org the store is
both run by and The Print Shop is owned
and run by this wonderful couple uh in
the middle of the country and they have
put one of the newer products um is they
put together a Pinon button set you get
these 12 12 little buttons for only 10
bucks and it's some of our some of our
best our most popular visuals so these
look great I haven't seen them yet but
um they look great and uh if I may uh
remind us of a conversation we discussed
before the Dark Horse pin is an
excellent way of subtly broadcasting to
other people that you might be wrong but
you're not crazy and if people who might
be wrong but are not crazy were to find
each other and have conversations it
might make the world a better place it
might it might
uh so indeed okay you can take that down
now if you like
um we've got of course hunter-gatherer's
guide the 21st century which there are
signed copies available at darvel's here
in the San Juans on Orcas uh you can get
it anywhere bugs are sold unsigned and
we are supported by you our audience for
whom we are eternally grateful We
Appreciate You subscribing to the
channel channels we're here on YouTube
We're on Odyssey we've got Clips
channels as well Dark Horse podcast
Clips Please Subscribe like share and
um you can also support us by joining
either our patreons Brett had one of his
patreon conversations this morning and
you're gonna have another one tomorrow
yes and I I assume it as always went
very well and fantastic they are always
surprising and
um uh I love meeting the new people who
show up there's long-standing folks
who've been there for years and anyway
it's uh it's a very interesting
experiment in gathering people uh around
Loosely shared beliefs and then having
vigorous Converse stations over what we
differ and where we're where we're
aligned anyway it's very good stuff
a group of people who are willing to be
wrong but aren't crazy yes willing to be
wrong but not crazy yeah that's awesome
and we had our private q a um associated
with my patreon last last week and those
are always fun as well so uh consider
joining us there on either our patrons
you also get access to our Discord
server where there are always people
talking
um in ways that suggests that once again
willing to be wrong not crazy
um so check that out check any of those
things out and of course we have
sponsors to whom we are also very very
grateful
for whom we are grateful we pick and
choose our
um the organizations which we affiliate
carefully and this week as always we
have three it's seed American Hartford
gold and mind Bloom and without further
Ado let us do these hats
there's a little bit of a do yeah it got
done though what is it do
uh it's just Shakespeare for do yeah I
was gonna I was gonna be ending I was
gonna quote Shakespeare but I think this
is the wrong spot
yeah yeah
so our first sponsor this week is seed a
probiotic that actually works your gut
and your immune system work together
coordinating your body's response to the
world both around and within you
seed helps improve the health of your
gut microbiome which means it supports
you becoming healthier overall
once you decide to take seed though how
will you remember to do so try habit
stacking build a major habit by starting
small for instance I have it stacked by
keeping a sentence a day Journal by the
side of my bed I see it every night it's
a low bar to write just a single
sentence I've been doing this for years
at this point and I've got an
interesting accumulating record of
something from every day for the last
several years that struck me
similarly if you want to have it stack
and get in the habit of taking an
actually truly efficacious probiotic if
you take seed first thing in the morning
leave the jar on the counter for
instance each night so it's the first
thing you see when you get up but why
would you want to well seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic is a plant-based Prebiotic and
probiotic with 24 strains that have been
clinically or scientifically studied for
their benefits 16 of those 24 strains
are specifically geared toward Digestive
Health as you would expect from a
probiotic for the 24 probiotic strains
are known to promote healthy skin your
skin like your gut has its own
microbiome and and Seed therefore
supports both gut and skin health
seed is also free from 14 major classes
of allergens including but not limited
to sugar animal products soy gluten
peanut glyphosate Dairy shellfish and
corn and seed is basically double halt
with its capsule in capsule design it is
engineered to maintain viability through
your digestive tract until it reaches
your colon where you want it and the
same design also makes it resistant to
oxygen moisture and heat meaning that
unlike many probiotics no Refrigeration
is necessary it's easy to travel with
you don't have to find a refrigerator as
soon as you land or whatever
so you take two capsules once a day on
an empty stomach could be the first
thing in the morning 30 minutes before
your first meal or two hours after your
last meal
seeds daily symbiotic that's syn biotic
supports scut skin and heart health and
micronutrient synthesis and we have
heard from several people who have used
seed and Report improvements to the
digestive function in 24 to 48 hours and
we both use it and uh and really like it
a lot so start a new healthy habit today
visit seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse to redeem 25 off your first
month of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
that's seed.com
s-e-eed.com not c-e-d-e that's seed
s-e-e-d as an inter seed right I know
okay and now I'm being confusing that's
seed.com
s-e-eed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse to get 25 off your first month
did you know that without skin
podcasting would be impossible
amazing how about chemistry
oh good yes now this is I can't say meta
anymore we can't say Trump and we can't
say meta anything else you want to take
out of the large language model that
most of us use to communicate woman
that one I still use oh well but you
also say all these other things don't
you no that is true that's true but
you're not supposed to
not supposed to that's kind of my thing
I know
okay this episode is also sponsored by
American Hartford gold if you listen to
Darkhorse then you likely know just how
incompetent and unstable many of our
institutions are becoming
inflation is at its highest level in 40
years interest rates are Sky High where
caught between runaway inflation and a
recession and our leaders are
increasingly nonsensical all of this
certain businesses jobs and retirement
funds finding ways to secure your nest
egg and insulate your wealth is more
important than ever and adding precious
metals to your assets is a great way to
stabilize your Investments and protect
yourself financially American Heart for
gold is a precious metals dealer that
can help you do just that American
Hartford gold helps individuals and
families protect their wealth by
diversifying with precious metals they
make it simple and easy to protect your
savings and retirement accounts with
physical gold and silver
with one short phone call they can have
physical gold and silver delivered right
to your door or inside your IRA or 401K
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an A plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients and if you call them
right now they will give you five
thousand dollars nope they will give you
up to five thousand dollars of free
silver on your first qualifying order
contact them today by visiting a link in
the episode description it's already
there in the show notes or call
866-828-1117 that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to
998899 once again to reach American
Hartford gold call
866-828-1117 check out the link in the
show notes already or text Darkhorse to
998899 cover your assets in metals
all right awesome uh our final sponsor
this week is mind Bloom mind Bloom is
the leader in at home ketamine therapy
offering a combination of scientifically
robust medicine with clinically guided
support for people looking to improve
their mental health and well-being
if you or someone you love is struggling
with mental health issues those issues
May Loom large in your life there is no
one-size-fits-all solution but you know
that you or your loved one need
something that will help achieve a real
and Lasting breakthrough maybe it's time
for you to check out a guided ketamine
Therapy Program from mind Bloom mind
Bloom could be your next and most
successful chapter in mental health and
well-being
mind Bloom connects patients to license
like psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower cost
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience
to begin take mind Bloom's online
assessment and schedule a video consult
with licensed clinician to determine if
mind Bloom is right for you if approved
you'll discuss your health history and
goals for mental health treatment with
your clinician to tailor your mind Bloom
regimen mind Bloom will send you a kit
in the mail complete with medicine and
treatment materials and tips for getting
the most out of your experience after
only four sessions 89 percent of Mind
Bloom clients reported improvements in
their symptoms of depression and anxiety
reports one client on their site I
thought I was broken now the light
inside me is growing stronger every day
let mind Bloom guide you into a better
chapter of mental health and well-being
right now mind Bloom is offering our
listeners a hundred dollars off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com Darkhorse and use
the promo code Darkhorse at checkout go
to mindbloom.com
darkhorsement.com Darkhorse use the
promo code Darkhorse for a hundred
dollars off your first six session
program today that's mindbloom.com
Darkhorse promo code Darkhorse
starts to sound ridiculous on the tongue
after you say it that many times you
know it's funny I have this uh as a a
lifelong uh recovering dyslexic or
whatever the hell I am every time I read
something new out loud there is a kind
of Terror that I will lose my access to
whatever mental processing equipment it
is that allows a person to read and I
suddenly will be staring at a bunch of
letters and not know how to string them
together and it only rarely happens well
I think in order to call yourself
recovering you need to know how long
it's been since you've just dyslexed
um so I'm not sure you count as
recovering no I know I'm planning to
recover let's put it that way well well
good luck with that thank you
all right
um
right now as as we speak as as we live
and breathe uh midday Saturday April 1st
um the hashtag boycott 60 Minutes is
trending on Twitter
and I saw this uh also Leslie Stahl is
Twin twending it's twending on Twitter
[Laughter]
um that was Barbara Walters intruding on
the Leslie Stahl discussion that's right
uh Leslie Stahl is also trending on
Twitter and she's of course one of the
hosts of uh 60 Minutes 60 Minutes being
this long running hour-long show on
Sunday evenings on CBS that before
podcast became a thing was kind of the
longest form uh visual media way that
you ended up with with stories with
interviews like it like you know they're
not that long but it was really
substantial I used to I used to watch it
uh regularly when I was a kid back when
there was journalism rights right and uh
thus he became informed I became right
uh largely informed occasionally
misinformed uh I was sometimes
malinformed and that was not terrorism
at the time no no no not at all but
right yeah the um both the McNiel and
our NewsHour back when PBS was Alive and
Kicking
yeah yeah 60 Minutes was more
um more entertaining but um often some
you know remarkably hard-hitting stories
and also they um they are effectively
reflecting back because they're doing
journalism they're supposed to be
reflecting back some of what the biggest
stories are that people are thinking
about or should be thinking about uh in
in the world at the moment so you know
high production values your big budget
large stopwatch very large stopwatch and
you know you got to know about how that
would sound if it was in your living
room if you were any good at math you
could figure out how much of a
television program was commercials by
the fact that 60 Minutes contains
something like 43 minutes well I was
gonna say it was often two or three
interviews plus some Preamble plus was
it Andy Rooney at the end is that right
yeah
yeah and so and yet you know maybe these
are sort of 12 minute total content wise
these interviews but but again uh this
this was as deep as you would go in in
mainstream media and Intel Intel podcast
mostly
um so hashtag boycott 60 Minutes wow
what did they do well what they did
apparently and it hasn't even happened
yet it's gonna the segment is going to
air tomorrow as we as pre-crimes we're
in the pre-crime segment but the crime's
already been committed it's just not
public yet so on April 2nd apparently
they are going to for their for their
Sunday show uh they are going to reveal
the again high production value results
of the set of interviews that Leslie
Stahl did with
wait for it the gall of the woman the
inhumanity She interviewed Marjorie
Taylor green
Marjorie Taylor green who if you've been
living under a rock is a an elected
official
a congresswoman in the House of
Representatives of the United States of
America representing Georgia
we don't live in Georgia we didn't vote
for her probably wouldn't have voted for
her if we did live there but I don't
know right she's there she's an elected
official
she has some
remarkable view she's the AOC she's the
AOC of the red she's she's the AOC of
the red team and um
you know I think that both of those
women have something to offer and a lot
of what they are is a dog and pony show
both of them
what ah that seems dangerous but uh I'm
I'm all for it uh yeah a dog and pony
I'm not calling either them dogs or
ponies right I'm I'm saying that so much
of it is for show and yet at base both
AOC and Marjorie Taylor green appear to
have some fundamental values
um that I share
and I probably won't watch this just
like I probably wouldn't watch a Leslie
Stahl interview with AOC
but the idea that
Leslie Stahl just sitting down and
talking with
an elected official in the House of
Representatives in the United States of
America is enough to get the Twitter mob
out in force and say basically for shame
for shame how could you don't you you do
not talk to those sorts of people is I
think really indicative of the moment
that we are living in and that was the
segue by which I wanted to introduce
some of this
um Thomas Seoul thinking but so it's a
tell it doesn't tell the point is let's
say that you think Marjorie Taylor green
is
um
some sort of a terrible disaster and
affront to good governance or something
like that right
that's a reasonable thing to think
you should want her interviewed it will
reveal itself or you will discover that
it isn't true right the idea but that
that that's the danger isn't it what if
some people discover it's not true well
so this is in fact uh one of the central
tools of the moment is
um
penalizing people for open-mindedness
right and this you know we of course
were cast into the public eye with
exactly such a thing right we were
Beyond The Pale for questioning a policy
change at our college that we were
actually obligated as faculty members to
question if we thought it was
questionable so uh you know
de-platforming people
I'm driving up the costs of voicing
skepticism or Nuance which is really
what it is right
um that tool is the kind of thing that
you would want if the division of let's
say Americans was serving your interests
if you needed Americans divided because
if Americans were to actually talk to
each other they would find that they
were for example
uh all being shafted by the duopoly and
that because it is a majority of
Americans whose interest lies in
overthrowing the duopoly that they might
do that so if you needed the duopoly to
maintain its position so that it could
do your bidding at the expense of the
public
then you really wouldn't want people
listening to the other side and so
whether it's you know Donald Trump is so
evil that you dare not listen to what
the man says or Marjorie Taylor green or
AOC or you and me right it's it's all of
us this is their tool and so you know I
will say the correct principle is read
the books they wish to burn right listen
to the people they don't want you to
hear and you know what sometimes you
will find that they're starkcraving mad
and sometimes you will find they are a
little bit of each
right a little bit of what what's the
each start craving mad with some insight
Insight right
um so anyway by listening you're not
agreeing to what they say you're just I
mean maybe you're even just listening to
hear why they are persuasive to others
oh my God they're you know there are so
many reasons to both let everyone speak
and to in fact listen to those with whom
you are certain you disagree
and I cannot actually come up with any
legitimate reason to shut down the
ability for people to be you know
interviewed on 60 Minutes for instance
and
you know I think I saw this I then went
and looked at the 60 Minutes tweet about
this and at Marjorie Taylor greens
either retweet or you know you know
going public with this and
um they're both just very reasonable you
know I think I think 60 minutes because
it's not a person it's this entity
doesn't state
this and I said so I think it was Margie
Taylor green who says look
um I had a great set of conversations
with Leslie stall and we don't agree
about a lot of stuff but um but here we
go I feel honored to have been invited
to have the conversations and uh you
know please listen
yeah I mean good yes please listen the
people your enemy are the people who
don't want you to listen to the people
who are supposed to be your enemy
exactly right listening to them is not
uh you know you have a mind for so that
you can discern what's reasonable and
what is not and somebody can say
terrible things and it doesn't have to
persuade you and you don't have to feel
jeopardized by it and you should know
what they're saying that's right
so
um three episodes ago I guess episode
Dark Horse 165 we discussed and read a
few experts excuse me excerpts from Paul
tillich's work tillage was a german-born
theologian who uh came to the United
States before World War II and then did
these radio broadcasts with the help of
the U.S office of War information that
were broadcast into into Germany during
the Third Reich to help basically she
was trying to wake up the German
populace to what was happening
and it's really an extraordinary thinker
and in the wake of that a um a
I gotta say acquaintance at this point
because we don't we haven't interacted a
lot but I you know I hope that we meet
in real life at some point and become
friends with
um the amazing extremely talented
Clifton Duncan uh who was an
up-and-coming singer and actor just
remarkably talented and I'll put a link
to his YouTube channel in the show notes
um his blossoming career on stage and
screen was cut short by his refusal to
comply with vaccine mandates so you will
find him like he will he should check
out his YouTube channel and you can also
find him on Twitter
um often just railing against the the
stupid and the certainty of the of the
people who are
so sure they're on the right side of
history in keeping people like him from
being in front of those of us who would
be interested in hearing a fabulous
voice and and seeing the talents of such
a
uh such an actor anyway he reached out
to me and said you know what you were
sharing about tillich has been explored
at some in some depth by um Thomas
Sewell
and he referenced a couple of works that
I had but also this massive book
intellectuals and society which I had
not owned and he specifically pointed me
to a few things so I bought it and uh I
want to share just a few excerpts from
it here today for us to talk about
um there are four excerpts I think after
each of them we can we can discuss a
little bit uh and they are all from
chapter 10.
which and so this was a uh 2011 book
first published in 2011 it's been
updated with some chapters added uh for
republication in 2021 but the original
text uh is from over 10 years ago at
this point and uh it was this bad
already then let's keep that in mind
okay so chapter 10 all of these are from
chapter 10 which is called filtering
reality
this first excerpt is the beginning of
the chapter filtering reality in Thomas
sewell's intellectuals and Society I
think it's Soul isn't it soul I think so
keep trying to say soul and then I see
how it's spelled and I can't do it yeah
the problem is we have a soul right in
our uh that's so it's it is I I think
like Alma like I'm gonna go Seoul all
like I'm gonna pronounce it like that
and I then I can't
right Thomas Seoul Thomas
not Soul right
okay filtering reality
the preservation of the vision of the
anointed has led many among the
intelligencia to vigorous and even
desperate expedience including the
filtering out of facts the redefinition
of words and for some intellectuals
challenging the very idea of Truth
itself
many among the Intelligentsia create
their own reality whether deliberately
or Not by filtering out information
contrary to their conception of how the
world is or ought to be
some have gone further J.A schumpeter
said that the first thing a man will do
for his ideals is lie
it is not necessary to lie however in
order to deceive when filtering will
accomplish the same purpose this can
take the form of reporting selective and
atypical samples suppressing some facts
altogether or filtering out the
inconvenient meanings or connotations of
words
with regard to selective samples
Soul rights filtering the sample of
information available to the public can
take many forms for example Bennett kerf
or surf I'm not sure which the founder
of Random House Publishers at one time
during the second world war suggested
the books critical of the Soviet Union
be withdrawn from circulation
when the American economy was recovering
from a recession in 1983 and
unemployment was down and 45 out of the
50 states ABC News simply chose to
feature a report on one of the five
states where that was not so or as they
put it quote where unemployment is most
severe
as if these states were just more severe
examples of a more General condition
when in fact they were very atypical of
existing Trends in unemployment
so that's the first little excerpt
um just his his framing of the issue and
two examples
um
of how in the past media has led well
the first one is a call for actual
censorship of books
um but the idea that ABC looked at 50
states found a trend that should make
all of us feel good in 45 of 50 of them
and decided to report on one of the
others while actively alighting the fact
that this was the exception
is well as you said earlier you know
back when journalism was happening this
was this was back when journalism was
was supposedly happening and and still
this uh filtering of facts uh while
making it seem that you are getting the
you know the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth has has never been
the case
honestly so
there is a very deep question here
the license
to adjust the presentation of reality in
the truth-seeking Realms you know
journalism uh the courts
science science in the University system
yeah uh all of the places where truth is
sought
there is always an argument to be made
that certain truths are
counterproductive and that we would be
better off either adjusting them so that
we do we present the thing that is most
useful to believe or editing those which
are inconvenient and presenting those
that go on narrative there's always this
argument
it needs to be settled exactly once
the fact is you don't have a right to do
that because truth seeking itself is
incredibly value and valuable in moving
forward and what that means and this is
you know was obvious to the founders for
example what that means is that you must
suffer the costs that truth inevitably
brings in order to get its benefits
right just as the enemy is always those
who don't want you to hear your enemy
right the enemy is always those who are
arguing in favor of their right to edit
the truth for utility now the problem
with that that all is very clear I think
problem with that
and you know I would say for example
uh literally false metaphorically true
right
here you have clear evolved stories that
are not literally true they are in fact
in many places in conflict with what we
can discover to be literally true but
obviously have utility and I'm not
attacking those things those things are
valuable have been valuable what I'm
saying is they don't belong in the
laboratory right the place where you're
seeking truth is not a place or
metaphorical truth right it is a place
for literal truth the problem however is
the universe is a very complex place
and we understand a lot in some places
and very little in some others and you
have to have a mechanism for dealing
with the stuff that you don't get yet
right A lot of the stuff in the bio 101
textbook is [__]
but I call it [__] because it's not
done correctly it does not acknowledge
we don't exactly know what takes place
here but here is something that could
fit that space and we will find out over
time how much of this is right and how
much of this is nonsense right but
putting a lot of black boxes into a bio
101 textbook
uh will not suit the professor who
doesn't want any questions will not suit
the eager undergraduate maybe pre-health
or
um or just is you know things that they
need the answers and they need to know
exactly what they are and uncertainty is
uncomfortable
so those textbooks that have actual
black boxes that say we're not sure
about what goes here it might be this it
might be this but we know that we start
at a and we end at F and we're not sure
what B through E look like uh would be a
much better textbook in terms of
teaching people actually how to think
scientifically but it does not fit with
people's expectation of certainty well
and the expectation of certainty varies
with topic
in other words the thing that always
troubled me about the bio textbook was
that it was written in the same style as
the chem textbook and the fact is
introchem
we do have a really good idea how all
that stuff works we are encyclopedic now
there's a place you go far enough in
chemistry you get to a place where we're
confused again but it isn't in the intro
textbook in the bio textbook it ought to
be all over that thing and so they
shouldn't be written as similarly
encyclopedia I agree with you I will
just just asterisk here um that you know
chemistry also uses metaphor right like
you know all the science all the
Sciences he's metaphor and many
scientists if you say that to them like
I most certainly do not right what are
you talking about but you know the
example for me and you've heard this
before is like you know orbitals like
you know it's not it's it's not those
neat little little concentric shells uh
like like they make out it to be and you
know increasingly I think that there is
discussion of cloud rather than shells
and and such but um but it is simplified
even even if the actual understanding
that we have is is better at the level
of basic chemistry than basic biology in
some places the intro textbooks are
still written as if it is more simple
unless nuanced and we are more certain
than we actually are yeah it's just that
the difference between the chemistry and
the biologies orders of magnitude in
terms of what fraction we understand
because of the difference in complexity
right because of the difference in
complexity absolutely and there's
another issue which we hinted at at the
beginning of the podcast
how are we to depict a neuron that has
you know a thousand several thousand
dendritic connections to other neurons
you could have just a sea of
complexity and then the student doesn't
understand the neuron or you could
simplify it and then they get the wrong
idea of the neuron and it gets overly
ingrained and
one of the I I become troubled by this
over time never figured out exactly what
the right thing to do is other than just
to call attention to it
the capacity of something especially
something visually compelling
to mislead the mind is so great that
when we do diagram a neuron and has
eight dendrites and one axon and the
number of axons is right but the number
of dendrites is way the hell off
um
we create that broken model in the mind
and the point is it's like a snowplow
when you're skiing right the snow plow
might be how yeah yeah it's a low
adaptive Peak and it's hard to get out
of it right it's once you've learned
that a snowplow is how you can control
your speed it's hard to pull your skis
together and learn to you know use a
turn to control your speed
um so anyway we because it requires that
you are facing downhill with no brakes
yeah at some moment in every turn yeah
you are crossing the fall line and and
so we've got to figure out how you own
up to this ahead of time you tell the
student look there's a thing that you
have to do temporarily
and it's not right
but you're gonna get this first and then
we're gonna fix it later and if we got
good at saying that we're gonna you know
either this is something we've learned
like the image comes up with an asterisk
like okay you can now visualize that
that neuron but have that access and
have that asterisk in your head as well
that's part of the visual right this is
50 wrong or ten percent wrong or
something yeah I wouldn't quantify it
either but but something to indicate
that there is something that learning
this thing will make you feel clever but
there's a next stage which is going to
make it feel dumb or something right
um that is really important and I was
actually prone to think about this uh
our family watched
um
looks at 13 days the muscle crisis about
yeah the Cuban Missile Crisis in 1968
two three uh it's got to be two
um but in any case really well done high
production values they go through a lot
of effort to represent the the scenes
and the people in ways you know doesn't
look like JFK exactly but close enough
and anyway but you know so I went and I
uh looked it up how accurate was this
portrayal and highly accurate in terms
of narrative uh of the progression of
the Missile Crisis not highly accurate
with respect to the personalities
involved in fact
the main character is actually kind of a
nobody in the white house
um yeah so so the main character in the
film is is brought up to tell the story
but actually wasn't wasn't particularly
anything as far as anyone he knows he is
not a not an important player and he was
or not nearly so important to player and
he's used as a narrative device to make
the story work
um he gets he gets told things he
introduces ideas that otherwise you have
to like put script on screen or
something right and he drives you know
the Kennedys to find the best in
themselves and to stand up when they
have to and these things and uh anyway
how much does the representation because
this is not a fictionalization of the
Cuban Missile Crisis because it
accurately represents something that you
know you and I didn't live through we're
not old enough to have lived through it
much less lived through it at an old
enough age to rock it in real time so
the representation of the Cuban Missile
Crisis that we see on screen comes to
supplant the actual history but for a
large number of people it's not a
fictionalization it is it's Fiction it's
it's it's portrayed as historical
fiction which in a historical fiction is
a is a broad genre uh in which in which
I think you hope for
uh the ability to learn some truth about
history but any particular thing that
you take from historical fiction you
would want to fact check that of course
for assuming that it was actually
something that was being conveyed
accurately but I can see that you like I
were surprised that the main character
in the film is not an important player
in the Kennedy White House right right I
guess I was just objecting to like of
course it's a fictionalization well but
you know I guess the point is then
fiction is such a huge category from you
know the dialogue is made up but the
events are accurate to this person is
actually not really is playing a role
that was not played but is necessary to
get the story told in two hours right
um you know this that's a whole other
conversation right like what in a police
procedural or something like what's a
dramatization yeah dramatization is as
far as we are led to believe supposed to
be an actual accurate portrayal of what
happened but of course
no one knows for sure exactly what all
happened and this particular
dramatization May
value
um the will inherently value the
perceptions and the hypotheses of the
person who put that together at the time
maybe they're right maybe they're wrong
well
and so this this goes back to my my
point about textbooks and things like
this
the degree of Damage Done to our
historical understanding by the movie 13
days is very tiny in fact probably it is
a vast upgrade in terms of the fraction
of the population that understands what
the events were and and all of that
the Damage Done by something that you
know inverts a story right that makes
you know the Allies uh that makes the US
the hero of the Allies rather than
acknowledging the huge amount of the
winning of World War II that was done by
the Russians for example yeah
um is you know destructive of our
understanding of history and the basic
underlying point is truth seeking is
about truth seeking we don't get to tell
stories that uh increase our Valor at
the expense of truth because the point
is the truth seeking is like a sacred uh
or should be sacred meaning we should
not mess with it to that point we have
several more examples of exactly this
from down his soul
from again intellectuals and Society
homelessness he writes is another area
where much of the media filters where
much of the media filters what kind of
reality gets through to Their audience
during his time at CBS News Bernard
Goldberg noticed the difference between
what he saw on the street and what was
being broadcast on television
he said in the 1980s I started noticing
that the homeless people we showed on
the news didn't look very much like the
homeless people I was tripping over on
the sidewalk the ones on the sidewalk by
and large were Winos or drug addicts or
schizophrenics they mumbled crazy things
or gave you the evil eye when they put
paper coffee cups in your face and asked
for money
but the ones we like to show on
television were different they looked as
if they came from your neighborhood and
mine they looked like us and the message
from TV news they didn't just look like
us they were like us on NBC Tom Brokaw
said the homeless are quote people you
know
if the homeless tend to be sanitized in
television news businessmen tend to be
demonized in movies and television
dramas as another study found quote
only 37 of the fictional entrepreneurs
played positive roles and the proportion
of bad guy businessmen was almost
doubled out of all other occupations
what's more they were really nasty
committing 40 of the murders and 44 of
the vice crimes only eight percent of
prime time criminals were black
end quote
by continuing with what Saul writes
Soul yes in real life as well as in
fiction what was presented to television
audiences was highly atypical of what
existed in the real world
um another example During the period
studied six percent of the people with
AIDS shown on the Evening News were gay
men but in real life 58 were gay men
on TV 16 were blacks and Hispanics but
in real life 46 were Black Or Hispanic
on TV two percent of the AIDS sufferers
were IV drug users in real life 23
percent were
this creation of a picture reflecting
the vision of the anointed rather than
the realities of the world extends to
textbooks used in schools Publishers
such as McGraw-Hill for example have
percentage guidelines as to how many of
the people shown in photographs and
their textbooks have to be black white
hispanic and disabled moreover the way
these individuals are portrayed must
also reflect the vision of the anointed
according to the Wall Street Journal
quote one major publisher vetoed a photo
of a Barefoot child in an African
village on the ground the lack of
Footwear reinforced The Stereotype of
poverty on that continent end quote in
short the painfully blatant reality of
desperate poverty in much of Africa is
waved aside as a stereotype because it
does not fit the vision to be portrayed
even if it does fit
the facts
wow that's numbered that's the second of
the four excerpts I wanted to share from
Thomas Soules intellectuals and Society
so I want to point to two things one
um Michael schellenberger uh did a
tremendous amount in much more recent
times to reveal the the
factual bankruptcy of the idea that what
we have is a homelessness crisis
right homelessness is a symptom of a
different crisis and it is a euphemism
that obscures the problem so that lots
of people labor under the
misapprehension
the problem is not enough homes and rent
being too expensive or something like
that
um and we talked about this his book is
extraordinary and we talked about this
in some live streams past yep yeah um
but he also he also did the service as
many people now are doing but he also
did the service of just taking the
camera out of the streets in the Bay
Area specifically in San Francisco and
saying Yep this this is what I'm saying
this is what is happening and he
interviewed people and it was amazing
how open they were about their drug
addictions and uh what kind of
hospitable environment they find for
their vices in San Francisco yes um I
actually just anecdotally and I'm not
going to give away the specifics so that
I don't I'm just going to anonymize the
person I heard this from but I was just
talking to someone in Portland
who said there's an interview up with
some homeless woman who was being asked
like why don't you go into the housing
that's been erected like you know we
there is actually some housing that has
been
uh put together but there are a few
rules like you know you don't there's no
drugs and there's um and you have to
keep the space clean and she said well
like what why would I leave this is
fantastic you get up you get high you go
get your free meal you come back you go
to sleep you get up you get high you get
your free meal you come back you go to
sleep repeat and no that's not
everyone's story but
her story and it's very much like what
shellenberger was seeing farther south
on the west coast in another major city
was you know if if you make
a life appealing to people who have
underlying problems that are not
entirely reducible to I do not have a
home then they will continue to choose
to live the life that you have made
appealing
yeah people navigate based on proxies
for well-being and unfortunately those
proxies are especially easily sidelined
by uh chemicals that interfere with the
motivational architecture so it's not
surprising that if you take the pain out
of losing your home and you facilitate
you know the pursuit of those chemicals
that lots of people will fail to find
the motivation to fix their lives and I
am not claiming that there is a solution
in that description what I'm claiming is
that it is obvious that you will
increase the problem if that's your
approach is to you know
to use compassion in a a naive way is of
course going to create a bigger problem
than than you initially had that's right
oh should I do the next one did you have
something else to say here okay
third of four excerpts from chapter 10
of Thomas Soules intellectuals in
society I can figure out
there it is
here we go suppressing facts
one of the historic
sorry my computer
one of the historic examples of
suppressing facts was the reporting and
non-reporting of the Soviet Union's
government created famine in the Ukraine
and the north caucuses that killed
millions of people in the 1930s
is going far back right
New York Times Moscow correspondent
Walter Durante wrote there is no famine
or actual starvation nor is there likely
to be
he received a Pulitzer Prize the
Pulitzer panel commending him for his
reports quote marked by scholarship
profundity impartiality sound judgment
and exceptional clarity
meanwhile British writer Malcolm
muggeridge reported from the Ukraine
that peasants there were in fact
starving quote I mean Starving in its
absolute sense not undernourished as for
instance most Oriental peasants and some
unemployed workers in Europe but having
had for weeks next to nothing to eat end
quote
mud muggerage majority I'm not sure how
to pronounce it wrote in a subsequent
article the man-made famine was quote
one of the most monstrous crimes in
history so terrible that people in the
future will scarcely be able to believe
it ever happened end quote decades later
a scholarly study by Robert Conquest the
Harvest of Sorrow estimated that 6
million people had died in that famine
over a period of three years
still later when the official archives
were finally opened in the last days of
the Soviet Union under Mikhail Gorbachev
new estimates of the deaths from the
main from the man-made famine were made
by various Scholars who had studied
material from those archives most of
their estimates equaled or exceeded Dr
conquest's earlier estimates
at the time of the famine however this
was one of the most successful filtering
operations imaginable
what muggerage said was dismissed as
quote a hysterical tirade by Beatrice
Webb co-author with her husband Sidney
Webb of an internationally known study
of the Soviet Union muggerage was
vilified was unable to get work as a
writer writer after his dispatches from
the Soviet Union and was so financially
strapped that he his wife and two small
children had to move in with friends
there is no need to believe that there
was any conspiracy among editors or
journalists to silence and ostracized
Malcolm muggerage nor is a conspiracy
necessary for successfully filtering out
things that do not fit the prevailing
Vision either then or now
except for mug origin of very few other
people
if famine deliberately used to break the
back of resistance to Stalin killing a
comparable or larger number of people as
those who died in the Nazi Holocaust
Holocaust would have been filtered
completely out of History instead of
being merely ignored as it usually is
today
this was not a matter of a matter of
honest Mistakes by Durante and others
what Durante said privately to some
other journalists and to diplomats at
the time was radically different from
what he said in his dispatches to the
New York Times for example in 1933 a
British Diplomat reported London quote
Mr Durante thinks it is quite possible
that as many as 10 million people may
have died directly or indirectly from
lack of food in the Soviet Union during
the past year
so when people wonder why it's important
that we know what for instance Anthony
fauci was saying privately early in
covid this is why
so this is why this is why and it also
reveals
um the complexity of the corruption of
such systems and soul is absolutely
right this does not require a conspiracy
what it requires is a system of
incentives that results in the story
being obscured right the journalist who
reports it finds themselves unable to
get work the journalist who obscures it
finds himself in possession of a
Pulitzer Prize actually they should call
it a Pulitzer Prize since he got that's
been done it's been done oh well all
right I feel derivative
um no I didn't I didn't but anyway
um this actually is a terrific moment to
um point then to Jacob Siegel's new
excellent article in tablet Magazine on
this very topic
um so what he has done is an exploration
to we have I have not seen yeah you have
uh Jacob Siegel's uh tablet article
um Jacob Siegel is a senior editor at
tablet magazine yep and here is his new
article maybe a tour de foreign for
those of you who are just listening it's
a it's a an oil or something of a crow
with a
digital eye
yep and the title of the article is a
guide to understanding The hoax of the
century anyway it is
um excellent it's quite a long article
we will post a link to it and what it
does is it explores the new architecture
for managing narratives
ostensibly uh in the National interest
but of course that's not how it works is
it this is a nation structure that has
been captured by special interests which
means interests that are counter to the
Public's interest that is foisting a
narrative on us that has all sorts of
ramifications be they medical fiscal
international relations environmental
and so anyway what you and I have been
talking about
um you know in terms of for example
Mystic and Mal information
uh is discussed here the article does
cover uh the shenanigans over kovid one
amongst many topics he's got 13 uh
different perspectives that he describes
anyway highly recommend it it's
definitely worth the investment of time
I also discovered this morning that
there is a glossary that tablet magazine
I hope they are just building it it's
not complete as it is but there appear
to be building a glossary of terms
relevant to information control I of
course uh furiously contacted them this
morning and said you need missed this
and Mal information and you need to
trace it back to the Department of
Homeland Security that introduced this
in their memo in uh February of the
2022. that's right um but anyway uh
follows perfectly from uh from Thomas
Souls
um words indeed it does okay one last uh
one last excerpt from Seoul for today
same chapter filtering reality in the
book intellectuals and Society first
published in 2011 republished with a few
added chapters although not this one I
think in 2021.
foreign
just as it is hard to find any
consistent correlation between gun
ownership and violent crime rates
internationally it is hard to find any
such correlation from historical
statistics within the United States
as one study noted quote
the United States experienced an
extraordinary increase in violent crime
in the 1960s and 1970s and a remarkable
drop in violent crime in the 1990s the
number of firearms especially handguns
and private hands increased by several
million every year during this period
the Relentless growth in the privately
held stock of firearms cannot explain
both the crime wave of the first period
and the crime drop of the second period
few of these facts
detrimental to gun control Advocates
case reached the general public although
there is no organized conspiracy to
block the truth
individual ad hoc filtering of what gets
through the media to the public can
readily add up to as completed
Distortion of reality as if there were
conscious coordination by heavy-handed
censorship or propaganda agency if those
individual journalists and editors who
do the filtering share the same General
Vision of what is and what ought to be
what seems plausible to those who share
that Vision can become the Criterion of
both believability and newsworthiness
plausibility however is the most
treacherous of all criteria for what
will seem plausible in a particular case
depends on what one already believes in
general
it is not necessary for either
individuals or a cabal to work out a
plan of deliberate deception for
filtering of information to produce a
distorted picture that resembles the
vision of the anointed rather than the
reality of the world
all that is necessary is that those in a
position to filter whether as reporters
editors teachers Scholars or Movie
Makers decide that there are certain
aspects of reality that the masses would
misunderstand and which a sense of
social responsibility requires those in
a position to filter to leave out this
applies far beyond issues of gun control
fantastic yeah as always he is uh right
on the money both analytically and also
the way he presents these things it's
just uh it hits you over that every time
yeah and
I can't at the moment think
of a major story to which this isn't
applying
right like this yep certainly the last
three years of Coven in which uh the
entire world and you know to some degree
us specifically have been informed that
you may not have those conversations you
may not investigate those those
questions because doing so
adds an element of Doubt into the minds
of the masses basically and you know the
argument is one of we and you know is
his argument his word it's the anointed
versus all the rest of us and uh at some
level you know what we have been accused
of doing is breaking ranks you like you
got your fancy degrees you're the
anointed don't do this yes right and you
know we
have somewhat fancy degree is but more
to the point are scientists yeah we've
got degrees in uh truth seeking right
and what actually are all of those other
people with supposed degrees in truth
seeking up to
because either they never could do it in
which case their degrees or Shams which
some of them are or they are actively
lying to themselves and or to everyone
else in which case they don't deserve to
stand as if with authority and speak
words that whether or not they know it
aren't true
what was the publication initial
publication 2011 2011. so I did want to
highlight one thing he's correct that
you don't need a conspiracy to get these
things
we however are living in 2023 we are and
the fact that a conspiracy is not
necessary to get this kind of narrative
control doesn't mean that we don't have
one and in fact it's out in the open
right that we see the Department of
Homeland Security warning us about Miss
dis and malinformation and oh by the way
it happens to be a form of terrorism
which creates a a whole
network of laws or
hesitate to call them laws because
they're clearly unconstitutional but
um but anyway
yes mechanisms are triggered by the
invoking of those syllables by the
executive of which the DHS is part and
so by defining certain beliefs DHS DHS
is part of the executive branch yeah
okay
um the point is the executive himself
our senile president in this case could
Define you as a terrorist for speaking
truth that was inconvenient to the
narrative which would be malinformation
for example and the fact that he
couldn't remember having done so half an
hour later is irrelevant all the better
it's a feature not a bug
um yeah so anyway the point is we have
we have seen conspiracies at many
different levels we have seen
conspiracies at the federal level
especially the executive branch we have
seen uh gavi we have seen the trusted
news initiative we have seen inside the
Twitter files and the point is there's a
vast bulwark uh attempting to control
the narrative in the interests of some
thing something that inhabits the
costume of our government but is really
a pretender
um
that thing is exerting tremendous
control and the point is look
this is an authoritarian a cryptically
authoritarian State the idea that yes
you don't need a conspiracy to get you
know news organizations to broadcast
something convenient to those that
butter their bread but it doesn't mean
you don't have one and in this case the
basic point is if you lived in the
Soviet Union in you know the 70s
you knew pretty well to ignore the
official proclamations of your
government even though they came through
an ostensibly journalistic establishment
at Pravda right I think so I mean I'm
actually increasingly I'm
very curious how people living in
various in particular spaces and times
in particular places and times
actually did regard what was happening
yeah
these last three years have been
eye-opening in terms of how people will
tie themselves in knots
uh to demonstrate to themselves and to
the rest of the world that they are the
good people on the right side of History
while explicitly being the opposite well
um I do think that this would have been
evident to any thinking person living
inside the Soviet Union and I think so
70s
um and I think that what we face is much
more confusing right because uh because
it isn't an authoritarian State and so
we don't expect it to lie to us at this
level and we don't expect it to punish
citizens because how of course would you
do that that would be illegal for the
federal government to punish citizens
for wrong think in the U.S what about
the First Amendment and yet we see it
happening through all of these
public-private Partnerships as they are
falsely called when we think of
corruption we come up with
you know the things that we've
experienced trying to drive through a
country in Latin America and being
stopped by the police and being told
that we need to give them cash before we
can continue on right that's the only
spot uh fine the on the spot fine which
we've literally had happened to us and
uh like that oh that's what corruption
looks like right uh being asked when I
went in to get my research permits in
Madagascar as a graduate student who was
literally making thirteen thousand
dollars a year and gotten a grant to do
my research in Madagascar
um by the person behind the counter
where's my Land Rover
that that was the first ask I
and Rover I ended up delivering a bottle
of whiskey like that it went down from
Land Rover to Whiskey like okay and
negotiation Works it'll do it right and
we went through computer
um this would have been in the 90s so
yeah it's like oh I didn't arrive in
Madagascar with the Mainframe for you so
um anyway that that's that's both the
cartoon version and yeah it does exist
like corruption does exist like that in
countries where there is such great
disparity of wealth and
um officials can line their pockets a
little bit by seeing who might have
money and extracting it from them but
that's not almost ever what it looks
like in the weird world and that doesn't
mean that corruption isn't happening
right and you know yes the kind of
corruption where some local Authority
extracts funds from people is bad with
the amount of harm done by the
large-scale very polite well-dressed uh
executive level corruption is vastly
greater
um and you know yeah I'd far rather be
asked pay in a bottle of whiskey every
time again sure yes
the world you can live in yeah not I
mean
but lest I be misunderstood
the the government of Madagascar is not
functional at least it certainly wasn't
in the 90s and oh it can't be right uh
so I'm not I'm not saying that that that
overall it's a more functional system
I'm saying if I had to choose between
these two kinds of corruption in
isolation
um the simple Tit for Tat exchange that
is visible and that is apparent to
everyone is far easier to contend with
um yes and uh anyway there's a much
longer conversation to be had but once
you've seen truly malignant government
um you
cannot help but see the point of the
Libertarians Libertarians are you know
tragically wrong on the game theory but
frankly I would much rather live in a
system uh harmed by the absence of
necessary laws than one in which the law
making Authority is corrupt and
malevolent and effective which is where
we are right
all right well I think that brings us to
the end of that
that little section happy little yeah
intellectuals in society that's what
they'll get you all of that uh so you
wanted
to revisit a large part of the
conversation that we had last week about
AI yeah I wanted to revisit one thing
and then update people on some stuff
that happened this week that is
definitely worthy of of noting
um the the revisiting involved the
conversation that was being had by
people who think about uh Ai and
existential risk
and what I saw you know we talked about
a taxonomy last week of uh different
levels of horror and the horrors the
three that we presented were you
presented uh a malevolent AI that views
humans as a competitor or a threat and
essentially
right and uh goes after us not
recognizing that having gotten rid of
their existential threat they will also
cease to exist but well yeah depending I
guess yeah I mean I I would I would say
that there is a version of this story in
which they figure out how to
solve their needs yeah but then there's
a that's a branch maybe that I shouldn't
have introduced but okay malevolent
malevolent AIS is the worst case
badly aligned AI that that isn't
malevolent but uh follows instructions
maybe too literally and yeah yeah the
the paperclip maximizer
um that's an existential threat of its
own
um
and then the third layer was the
derangement of the humans by having this
intellect to interact with to query to
request things of with no preparedness
for how one thinks about what it knows
what it doesn't know what effect it's
having on what people think is true and
basically I would say
um we came we civilization came unglued
over covid presumably in the pre-agi era
I don't think we can be certain of that
but
we came unglued and
now we have an accelerant dumped on that
same system without us having learned
seemingly any of the lessons that we
should have learned for what went wrong
in the information environment during
covet that is a disaster and what I
wanted to point to is that I think
the uh
folks who think about existential risk
and AGI are suffering from what is
called the availability heuristic which
is that you default to those things as
explanations you default to those things
that are uh
knowledgeable that you are knowledgeable
about that are close at hand and away
from things that you don't know how to
think about and so I have the sense that
you've got a bunch of folks
in the rationalist community and
adjacent communities
who are at least very experienced in
thinking about the malevolent Ai and the
paperclip maximizer and not so good
about thinking about human confusion in
fact they
um really [__] up coven pretty badly
they got suckered and uh ended up on the
wrong side of that discussion many times
I feel like a a analogous
standing in a slightly different place
to
you can employ the availability
heuristic or you can go sort of from
sveldian and that he wasn't the first
person who did this but he was the most
famous person who talked about the known
knowns the known unknowns the unknown
knowns and the unknown unknowns and it
is it is human nature uh to focus on the
no nuns and to some degree on the known
unknowns but the unknown knowns or
unknowns of course you don't Focus there
because you inherently don't know
yeah
um it is it is that that categorization
I miss Rumsfeld despite him being a
diabolical human but uh no he was the
Yogi Berra of uh international relations
and Military matters and
um you know where have we arrived I
don't know but we do end up quoting the
man more than that but are there others
or is it just that because I don't if I
remember I looked into it at one point
and he did not that's not original with
him
um and I don't remember
who it was original with but are there
other things that he says because he's
not the Yogi Berra of whatever
international relations if he has one no
no there are a couple others it'll take
me some time to oh
uh you don't go to a war with the Army
you want you go to war with the army
that you have right the Army you have
anyway there are a couple that's true
yeah
Yogi bearish yeah
hey hey Boo-Boo
I don't know where that came from
um all right so back to the AI question
so I do have the sense that the
existential risk AGI folks are very
focused on the two problems that they
think a lot about and enjoy and not
focused enough on the hey if you
actually solved maybe both of those are
alignment problems or maybe yeah let's
call them both alignment problems
malevolent and Confused AI yeah
um even if you solve those we still have
an existential threat in the confusion
layer no this is this is this now is
more of a taxonomy because before it was
just a categorization it's like one two
three these all exist without any
attempt to describe the relationship
between you just had to try something
right you just had a trichotomously
branching thing but I think that's right
I I think what you've just done which is
to say the malevolent and the confused
um are both of a type and can be dealt
with by the same brains who are thinking
carefully ish about AI but they aren't
thinking about they aren't thinking
evolutionary early or about the humans
the users well I think I'm borrowing
they can correct me if I'm wrong
the malevolent and Confused or
indifferent paperclip maximizing uh AI I
believe they would group those as the
existential risk AGI folks okay we group
those as alignment both of them so they
would say that I'm adding something and
I'm saying you've got a confusion layer
which is in and of itself an existential
threat
um it's an accelerant on all of the
terribleness that we saw during covid on
whatever the next thing is did I say
Trisomy you did you meant trichotomy oh
you meant it's a politics it's a
polytomy yeah all right now we are I was
sorry like I was thinking about
chromosomes we are not even inside
baseball at the front we are inside a
baseball they're just staring at it I'm
sorry I used totally the wrong word
cordage yeah yeah sorry sorry go on no
you're good yeah
um it's interesting how that stuff
remains in the buffer and then you find
it and you're like damn did I say that
what part of me said that I know exactly
anyway yeah yeah
um but okay so you've got the
existential threat that is not getting
widely discussed because it's you know
there aren't as
I guess there are now a couple uh sci-fi
films that cover it but um not not well
I think
so which brings me to the next part of
this
there was a weird kind of battle that
broke out right some very important
folks signed an open letter you want to
show the open letter
uh calling for a six-month moratorium on
training of AI systems above gpt4 above
opening above they don't want GPS
following five yeah Downstream of uh
upgraded more powerful than well now
that's all using all the metaphors I
don't think it's I don't think it's
vague I think the basic point is how
much stuff did you give it to read
right and we've seen at a certain level
what it can do at gpt4 and their point
is don't you dare give it a bigger
library because now we know we've got a
problem okay
so
more powerful than is what it says yeah
so more powerful means uh bigger bigger
Library
um now on the one hand
this is some really important people
sign this Elon Musk signed it I saw Jim
rutt's name there are a lot of people
whose names you would know some
important people in uh in AI research
I'm calling for a six-month moratorium
and then you had some important
dissenters most prominently is not as
part of the letter but people who came
out afterwards and said no people who
disagreed with the letter now
disagreement with the letter came in two
opposite forms one form not strong
enough yeah one form was not strong
enough so Eliza utkowski yeah would you
show his thing
so this is Eliza udkowski writing and
you're going to scroll down uh pausing
AI development
um pausing AI development something I
didn't catch the full title here I'm
gonna scroll back
closing AI developments isn't enough we
need to shut it all down okay and this
was a
um
it's a little hard to describe this
piece it's rare that one sees anything
written like this in a mainstream
publication or something that you know
has that uh as it's as its Legacy
but he basically says many of us who
think about this question believe that
the dawning of AGI will result in the
extinction of all of humanity the death
of all living people
um
and he goes on to clarify that
um he doesn't mean that there's some
remote Champs of it
that he thinks it's the likely outcome
now
um but there are also the sort of
Pollyanna objections to the letter
saying it's fine it's all going to be
fine right right now I will say yukowski
goes to udakowski goes to extraordinary
lengths and he advocates for things like
air strikes on servers that don't abide
by a moratorium on this kind of research
he advocates for
uh air strikes on servers that don't
abide by a complete shutdown of this
technology yeah okay now
that has been mocked by many people
um it is certainly uh it's either the
most serious existential threat to
humanity as he apparently is arguing I
haven't read his letter or it's not yeah
now I'm not supporting about the Bridge
Too Far well is it or is it not you know
the most serious existential threat to
humanity right now I actually like again
I haven't read it so I don't know that
that's his claim but it sounds like it's
at least close to the right neighborhood
of his claim right yes
um there's a question about how we are
to navigate such things obviously if you
had a runaway AI that was threatening
Humanity you know
we bomb stuff over much less than that
right a bit so uh obviously there's an
argument to be made on the other hand it
is not apparent that this style of
thinking is correctly anticipating what
comes it is certainly troubling that a
large number of people who appear
capable of high quality thought and are
expert in this area believe that there
is an alarming possibility of such a
thing
um but you know are are we to start
bombing people over you know somebody's
uh breathless claims in Time Magazine I
don't know that that doesn't sound like
any Planet I know about that wasn't a
time was it yeah it was yeah
um yadkowski's yutkowski yeah
so okay that's interesting so you've got
a letter with many uh mainstream folks
arguing for a six-month moratorium
you've got yukowski saying I refuse to
sign that letter because it didn't go
nearly far enough and advocating for a
you know military level response to
anybody who doesn't abide by a full
moratorium
um and then full and permanent
I believe so um and then
you have or not permanent I guess it
would be pending the development of uh
strategies that are sufficient to
contain this not clear that any such
thing is true and I would also possible
I would also point out in this milieu
it is not surprising
that something AGI like has emerged that
was completely obvious that that was
going to happen when exactly it was
going to happen okay maybe that's
surprising but to the extent
that's something about gpt4 has got
people talking about airstrikes on
server Farms it was obvious before TPT
3.5 that such a thing was down the road
so and I'm not saying that they didn't
have these discussions they did but the
point is
you know yes we are somewhere down this
road and we can now say something about
where that where we are but it's not
news that this was coming so to the
extent that there is a desire to put
together strategies that would contain
such a thing at the point that it was
developed
where were you six years ago why don't
we have those things why didn't you get
them ready and you know it's not that
they weren't trying but the point is you
think your moratorium is going to work
until we have those strategies but you
didn't really learn anything you didn't
know right you knew this was coming
so that's one thing the other thing is
the letter itself calling for a
moratorium
um
some of the folks in a rabbit hole that
I sometimes go down uh were having a
very excellent discussion about the game
theory surrounding this and this one was
bugging me uh from the point people
started talking about what do we do now
that now that AGI seems to have donned
well the question is anything you do at
the point that these horses have left
the barn
May disadvantage you relative to
somebody who doesn't agree to abide by
it right right so you know
who does that put an advantage right you
know is is open AI
you know our best hope or you know but I
mean that
obviously that raises the question about
okay so uh utkowski would have us bomb
server firms that don't abide worldwide
how do we know where like what what at a
practical level
precisely so the point is what utkowski
is advocating for is tantamount to a
commitment to attack let's say China if
it
four inches ahead and if we hold AI back
domestically and China forges ahead then
you know want how
I I don't I don't think I underestimate
the the risk here I'm very very
concerned but how would we no I mean one
of the things we all should have learned
in the last three years is that what
China says it's doing cannot necessarily
be trusted like how obvious is this yeah
it's pretty obvious and
um
you know my feeling and I don't know
what to do about it it's not that I
don't think these risks are real that
they're being overstated I think we are
now across the Event Horizon
I I think the quality of what virtually
everybody is saying on this matter is
low right predicting
across this event horizon is just not
working right we don't know where we
just landed we don't know how fast it's
going to progress
um the answer the only things that we
know I think are we aren't prepared and
um
we now have a potential emergency on our
hands well maybe maybe the metaphor
which is not in its original a metaphor
but the metaphor the way that we use it
of Event Horizon
is inadequate we have to combine it with
our what we propose in hunter-gatherers
guide with regard to hyper novelty and
the accelerating rate of change it's not
that we are over the Event Horizon we
may be over an event horizon and there
are how many more and they are coming at
us with how much more rapidity than they
did in the past that even if we find our
footing here the next one will hit us
and then we will have lost our footing
again
that's right now the the problem I I
mean of course as uh as co-participant
in in the creation of that idea of
course the point is we the hyper novel
yeah we've created a conveyor belt where
we keep getting hit with things that
upend all of the important stuff in
Civilization and you know we see all of
the great things that it will do for us
and we don't see the hazards until it's
too late and in fact even if you do see
the hazards until you can prove that the
hazard you know until you can be
specific and prove it there's no
mechanism for restraining this stuff and
at the point you can see the hazards and
prove it it's too late and I just I
I specifically am trying to make the
point that event horizon still seems
to everyone I think and you know you
just used it because it seems like the
most like that that is going to be the
thing that snaps us all to attention
like oh my God we are nowhere that we
have been before and we don't know what
we're doing and we don't know how to do
it or you know or we're approaching it
and we won't know necessarily at what
point we cross it but suddenly we will
not have the skills and the tools that
we need but it's this iterated event
horizon thing that hyper novelty like
combine the hyper the accelerating rate
of change in hyper novelty with the
Event Horizon metaphor and like oh it's
Event Horizon after Event Horizon after
Event Horizon
how do you plan like what do you do
so
um
the series of major disasters emerging
from
industrial and other processes that were
taking place at a scale that nobody in
the public understood until it was too
late right that pattern of things from
deep water Horizon
Fukushima Financial collapse of 2008
alizo Canyon leak
um
all of these things have the same
characteristic right we're doing
something when it works it works and
then at some point something happens
that causes the disaster to become
apparent and
all of these things have been at a scale
that while terrible
is manageable well and survival the
piece that we've written about and that
you've specifically talked about at some
length in various places is also that at
the point that it it explodes in some
way and the whole world is made aware
suddenly the vast vast vast majority of
us are like wait they're doing what
what that's a thing I how did how was
this upon the success of which
upon which we all depended for it to
just continue to thrum along in the
background if they were going to do it
at all how was that allowed to happen
without any buy-in right and so that it
does feel like the AI conversation is
like those right that like oh this this
has been happening and
um this does pose an existential risk
and we just didn't know well
unfortunately the one I left off that
list of major disasters is covet right
what were we doing
a function research on viruses we didn't
you know have a fraction of the
knowledge necessary to create we took
something from nature and turbocharged
it no we were just keeping ourselves
safe right and the point is oh how bad a
virus did you create uh real sucky not
gonna get rid of it but you know
survivable right it's a terrible
self-inflicted wound yeah but boy it's
not almost like anything else it's gonna
shorten lives
um you know well and
I mean it outright kills some people
right yeah
it shortens lives and that causes death
and people in it may shorten all of our
lives but
um but nonetheless that should have been
our wake-up call because you know what
it had the characteristics in order to
see the puzzle right it was
contagious right and therefore a tiny
little you know you've got a little
process taking place literally in a room
yeah right that results in a little
microscopic thing finding its way into a
cell and then the point is oh now the
world's stuck with this thing it
circulates between people it evolves on
its own completely out of control right
global scale this is part of why Origins
is so important these these monsters
frankly monsters
um because uh if the world comes to
understand for sure
what at this point should be obvious to
everyone this does not have a zoonotic
origin then obviously we shut down gain
of function research
right you should obviously on the other
hand I mean believe me we should have
shut down gain of function research and
we should figure out the big puzzle is
okay as I mean like Obama put a
moratorium on this stuff back in what
was it 2015 15 14 yeah and
like that was it was it was not unlike I
think I have not read this letter but it
you know the moratorium was eight years
ago on gain of function research was
like whoa can we just slow it down
seriously for a while while we assess
well we figure out what this means well
but it reveals the um the elephant in
the room as it were which is that
you're damned if you do and damned if
you don't right gain of function
research isn't that hard and so hey Zach
thanks
um the
the fact of oh we've got a process we
are now technologically sophisticated to
take a virus and make it effective of
humans where it wouldn't be and
contagious between humans
Etc oh well that would be pretty useful
to anybody who could figure one out and
figure out a remedy that only they had
right you know that obviates the need
for militaries frankly
um and so
the question is how could you possibly
have the sophistication to do this work
and
the ability to control that nobody else
does it if you decide it's a bad idea so
the answer is hey guess what
your Globe does not have governance
structures sophisticated enough to deal
with a problem you have now just
technologically created that is not
that's where we are with covet and other
infectious diseases it's where we are
with this AGI thing and so once again we
are in the position of how do we lock
the barn now that the horses have
escaped right right maybe this time the
um the existential risk AGI folks are
right and the point is up those horses
have escaped and there's very little we
can do
but at the very least let us understand
the lesson of this which is you know the
governance structures of the
18th century are not up to the challenge
of navigating this landscape paper saw a
lot of stuff
um couldn't foresee this and so anyway
that is a terrifying problem to have and
I think people feel
entitled to have a solution right they
felt entitled to have a solution to
covid and the fact is they didn't yes
yes
um so
anyway that's that's important people
feel entitled to a solution and there
may not be one and for some people
that's
not a possible answer
and so they assert that there is or
there must be a solution and uh and
March on blindly with that belief and
they think it's air strikes against
server Farms
um or something right or a six-month
moratorium which causes uh the AGI of
the West to fall behind the AGI of the
easts or I don't know what but yeah
anyway I guess at what point
do we get to say you know what
this was visible before and we are sick
of having conversations after the fact
yeah right this was visible before and
um
if you are right and I think your
formulation is correct we are over an
event horizon but it is not the Event
Horizon it is an event horizon then
if we survive this do we get now to have
the conversation about the fact that we
do not have governance structures that
are up to dealing with these things and
believe me having been through the
tyranny of coven
I am not excited about stronger
governance structures right I'm
terrified by them
um you know what we have is absolutely
malignant and we can't afford to have it
stronger on the other hand we can't
afford to have Technologies like this
when which people are empowered in their
basements or you know in a building
somewhere to unleash things on the world
that have profound impact on our you
know our medical well-being or on our
sanity you know that's that's not an
acceptable world and so uh it's it's
time to get it's time to get smart about
the recurrent Event Horizon problem
yes
very good
finally yeah
um I realized actually that we have an
armadillo behind us and some people
object to it
um but this is uh it's a holy armadillo
holy armadillo yes apparently
um
the um armadillo whose scientific name
is and I actually don't know if it's a
hard CH or if it's cater fractus or
chato fractus I'm gonna go with keto
practice filosis common name is the big
hairy armadillo okay so the big hairy
armadillo
um
which lives in South America there's
more than one of them but the species
lives in
Southern America they have gigantic
penises
and I came to know this in doing
research for my piece that I published
on my sub stack last week on the sleep
of seals
the connection may be and indeed should
be unclear yes it is I promise you it's
this side of the table so far I got
nothing yeah well okay so
um I am not now nor have I ever been a
man therefore I'm not in actual
possession of of a penis on my person
but as I understand it and as research
confirms men
uh have erections during REM sleep
apparently all the time like all the
time as do all the mammals where it's
been looked at really yes erections
during REM sleep all the animals where
it's been looked at
with one exception oh I think I know
what it is the big hairy armadillo
it's gigantic penis I don't actually
that's probably wrong but like seriously
it's supposed because it would be a
liability its penis is more than half
the length of its body not including it
do we know for why
okay right and so but they've got some
weird reproductive stuff like they I I
did not dive deep enough into like what
weird reproductive stuff they have and I
think we basically don't know but
seriously all the mammals that have been
looked at except for the big hairy
armadillo have REM sleep erections and
the big hairy armadillo does indeed have
erections during its sleep
but
only in non-rem sleep wait wait wait
wait wait I know
I'm telling you so um here you can show
my screen if you feel like it here we
have the paper in questions from 2001.
this was not published on April 1st I
know it's April Fool's Day right now but
absence of penile so paradoxical sleep
is just another word for REM sleep
absence of penile erections during
paradoxical sleep peculiar penile events
during wakefulness and slow wave sleep
in the armadillo now it turns that it's
not the armadillo it's just this one
species the common name which is the big
hairy armadillo
it's like
and this is
um this is one of the ways I'm used
myself yeah this is how you're spending
your time over the Event Horizon is that
it yeah exactly or between event
Horizons uh yes I'm going to read the um
I'm gonna read the abstract out loud oh
sure first the keywords though armadillo
paradoxical sleep penile erections slow
wave sleep voluntary erections and
wakefulness now if that isn't the best
list of keywords for any paper you've
ever heard I don't know what
who studies this stuff
these guys are in um Buenos Aires that
these are Argentinian doctors and
scientists good job guys
studying that oh you should check out
the methods
studying that topic suggests that we've
got so much stuff wired that I know for
sure we know nothing about right no but
you're not that guy like we've both
studied things it's like there is no
applied reason to do this but it's out
there it's happening I'm interested
science should know now I don't know if
that applies to this question but here's
the abstract
it sounds very
the electroencephalogram EEG together
with electromyogram EMG of the oh boy
ischio cavernosus Bobo cavernosus and
levator penis muscles were chronically
monitored across behavioral states of
the armadillo get her practice velosis
again the big hairy armadillo if you're
paying attention at home this animal has
a very long penis which exhibits
remarkable phenomena during wakefulness
slow wave sleep and paradoxical sleep
again paradoxical sleep just means REM
during wakefulness it remains retracted
within a skin receptacle
during slow wave sleep penile protrusion
can be observed together with very
complex movements
protrusion is a non-erectile event
during which the penis remains out of
its receptacle but without rigidity
penile erections are observed only
during slow wave sleep they don't mean
they don't get them when they're awake
because that's wrong they mean during
sleep
it's their second language that's the
excuse I think contrasting with other
mammals no erections occurred during
paradoxical sleep during this phase the
penile also share the etonia of the body
musculature characteristic of that phase
which raises the question
erections are apparently common in all
the other mammals
um that have been looked at in REM sleep
and otherwise you have etonia otherwise
you have an inability to move any
muscles except apparently for your penis
if you're that sort of person who has
one
some Reflections on mechanisms of those
penile events are presented
just got a couple
so am I
correctly that's the method section
involves
it's not a platysma graph
platysmograph yeah
I don't I don't get it yet what's a
platinum graph that's a uh penis blood
flow monitor oh no I think they're just
looking I mean these they're really big
it looks abstracted
like that no no they're doing
um well yeah actually electromyograms um
but I think those are they're getting
readouts they're not they don't think
they have it maybe they do I don't
remember honestly um I didn't pay so the
results
I love that the top of the results
section brief anatomical description of
the penis this description is necessary
in order to understand the results like
it actually should have gone into the
methods but okay the protruded penis
figure one is very long and in specimens
measuring 35 centimeters in length
excluding the tail is approximately 19
centimeters long wow
wow okay so one more little section here
we've got of course a diagram we've got
a baculum vacuum yeah of course you do
yeah I mean most mammals do that's the
penis bone yeah yeah
um so yeah I'm not so uh but then they
all I like how they introduce
language here the dominant sleep pasture
and posture in the laboratory is in
dorsal or lateral decabitus I looked it
up it's like that means they lie on
their backs they sleep on their backs
their science
come on guys do they okay okay I'm not
gonna hold on I think here we go
erections penile Behavior Arch like
erections occur these are the most
impressive phenomena they were always
accompanied by transient extensions of
the four limbs together with slight
changes in podcasts
penis adopted the form of an arch found
cavity downwards when the animal slept
in dorsal Deacon when the animal slept
on its back they were similar to those
observed during waking States in sight
of females
I think that's it yeah I think that's
all I got well I now know why you didn't
tell me this segment was coming I might
have called in sick I don't know but
yeah yeah all right well that's a wild
very strange very strong and I think
somebody needs to probably an
anthropology somebody needs to study
these researchers and see how it is that
they arrived at such a topic yes and I
mean there are some notes in there that
I haven't shared too about um
some particular erections that the
armadillo has experienced and and how
they were assessed
so I
though is it not that's yeah that that
um a there's been a whole lot of
research into under what sleep
conditions various species of animals
experience erections yep okay I mean at
one level do they have conferences about
that it's probably like a there's
probably a symposium at a larger
conferences right right yeah the um the
size of the conference doesn't matter
the Sleep erection symposia
oh
it does appear in armadillo I guess I
guess so I don't know I don't know
there's something there's something
reproductively interesting going on with
the armadillo I think genetically maybe
I think you know the size the the size
of the penis to to body size ratio like
no we know from the Adaptive test
described in
the hunter-gatherers guide I'm not
doubting it's adaptive yeah yeah yeah
but no there's the there's a damn good
reason for all of that architecture and
the um the pattern of erections during
different kinds of
I learned something I learned that
armadillos have REM sleep which I guess
isn't that a synapomorphy of mammals
something like that I think we think
it's a snap morphe which is to say a
shared derived characteristic new to
mammals or maybe it's just therians
which is to say all the mammals except
for the echidnas and the Platypus
although it may just be that it's hard
to assess REM sleep in the kidneys and
the Platypus
yes without laughing at least in the
Platypus I don't know how these people
did this work without laughing all the
time yeah no they probably did I don't
think the armadillos were laughing no so
like you pulled me out of where and
you're doing what no they have quite the
alien abduction story
and they weren't inside of any females
at all they were just having erections
during their sleep yeah well all right
that's all very strange okay that's
that's
where we have arrived yeah we have
arrived there somehow yep um I think
that's it all right I think we're gonna
do it we are for sure gonna do a q a
this week again not next week and uh the
week after that we will be gone but
we'll be back after that with more q a
but if you have questions for us
we will be back in about 15 minutes
you can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com and we will
answer as many as we can get through in
uh you know an hour or less should we
rename the podcast between two event
Horizons
anyway think about that
yeah which rolls off the tongue rolls
off the time yeah between two event
Horizons is I mean it's not inaccurate
no no
uh so uh until we see you next time
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside try to continue
persisting
[Music]
foreign